[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Applause]
[Music]
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
oh this guy's crazy
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
you'll see
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the batman
trailer they just released the dc fandom
it is hardcore there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs they talked a lot about
what's going on in the movie what his
version of batman is going to be like
how it's different from other versions
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a bunch of dc
movie trailers that they dropped this
weekend i'll be doing videos for
everything
i'm also doing a giveaway for a giant
box of dc fandom merch
that the dc people sent me so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from this trailer on the video
i'll just start at the beginning of the
footage and go through shot by shot they
open with a new red
dc movies logo because the official logo
of the movie is red it seems like red is
a very important color
during the movie there's a bunch of
extended scenes during the trailer where
everything goes red
usually that's a metaphor for blood but
it can mean a lot of things for the
story and the characters
the footage starts with a scene of the
riddler binding up his victim and
leaving clues for the batman that gordon
and the police the fbi find later
after which batman shows up in costume
at the crime scene to work with him
they explained that this is going to be
batman year two
confirmed but as you can see from a lot
of the designs in a lot of the
gear it still gives off a very batman
year one comic book vibe
like the riddler for example is not
wearing a question mark
bedazzled green jacket or top hat he
doesn't seem very silly
if the movie feels even more real world
down dirty and hardcore
than christopher nolan's batman dark
knight trilogy and the whole thing with
the aesthetic of the christian bale
batman was that they were asking the
question
what would batman be like in the real
world so they tried to make everything
feel
very real like what would it actually be
like if a billionaire decided to spend
his money to fight crime as a vigilante
and from the overall look of the movie
in the song that they put on the trailer
too the song they chose to use was
nirvana's something in the way that'll
probably give you guys flashbacks to the
90s
new batman movie with robert pattinson
seems like it's going to be even more
crazy and hardcore than previous batman
movies matt reeves did say it was meant
to be more of a detective movie like a
gritty neo-noir
crime thriller world's greatest
detective batman as opposed to say ben
affleck's larger than life big action
heavy justice league snyder cut batman
the riddler leaves his message reading
no more lies as he starts to leave clues
like comic book riddler the lies that
he's referring to probably have
something to do with the current
district attorney played by peter
sarsgaard who claims that his character
is a very very bad man in the movie who
lies falsifies evidence in order to
convict criminals
so it seems like the riddler is actually
trying to deal out what he feels like is
his own brand of vigilante
justice like part of the voiceover
message in the trailer says please do
not lie
and then you look at the newspaper
clippings of the district attorney's
cases that he's won
in court with lies written in red all
over them
you get a much better look at the new
batman costume as it's going to appear
in the actual movie as he walks in to
investigate the crime scene with gordon
it seems more like riot gear that he's
converted and modified like he's wearing
normal thick boots that you could buy at
any regular store on the street
really cool batman comic book easter
eggs that'll freak some of you guys out
in this greeting card that he leaves
batman there's a halloween themed owl on
the cover
that's one a huge easter egg for batman
the long halloween which the movie is
largely based on it's a big whodunit
murder mystery story involving all of
batman's biggest villains
and the owl is a big court of owl's
easter egg i don't know if the actual
court of owls are going to be featured
during this first movie but i think this
is meant to foreshadow them as villains
in the future batman sequels like the
joker playing card from batman begins
heralding his arrival in the next movie
the people that made the batman arkham
series also just made a brand new batman
game called gotham knights and the court
of owls are the main villains of that
new game
the gauntlets that batman has on his
armor also kind of seem like the
gauntlets that the court of alas talons
wear too
i dig all the rhyming that jeffrey
wright does as gordon during the trailer
footage just reading the riddler's
message to batman it's the riddler
that's doing all the rhyming gordon is
just reading the message to him
this person leading the press conference
for the police seems like he's the
current police commissioner who i
believe is meant to precede
gordon like he might be part of this
whole riddler subplot about him trying
to take out corrupt district attorneys
in possible corrupt police officers
paving the way for gordon to become
commissioner in the eventual sequels
this footage of batman without his
cowalon watching something from a
distance this is him riding up in a
motorcycle to watch this
police address to the press this is a
scene of him riding through the
graveyard we saw the behind the scenes
footage of earlier this year with his
stunt double
we also get the voiceover from andy
circus's alfred joking about batman
becoming something of a celebrity i feel
like every version of alfred in a batman
movie has had a version of a scene like
this with their version of batman
then there's him riding into his bat
cave so the way they cut this scene
implies that the entrance to the bat
cave is
in the cemetery or he has to drive
through the cemetery to get to it
that is hardcore but as you can see
around the batcave is way more sparse
than ben affleck's batcave just for
example or other
batman's bat caves that's just because
it's batman year two
he will accumulate trophies over time
i'm sure more vehicles
maybe even a giant penny or a dinosaur
at some point
this is the scene of the riddler sending
another message for batman leaving him
another clue but he's there as bruce
wayne so he saves this little kid from
being run over by this crazy car
the bomb later winds up going off when
he's inside his batman costume though
with a riddler message
what is the price for your blind eye
implying that he's going to make batman
suffer
if batman doesn't turn an eye to police
corruption
they kind of in the trailer on that
theme too the riddler trying to get the
batman
tied up in his quest to get rid of
corrupt people inside the system
as opposed to batman spending most of
his time running around beating up
common criminals on the street like you
see him do elsewhere in the trailer
we get our first look at catwoman
stealing something from a rich person's
house
it's hard to tell if this is wayne manor
or if this is somewhere else she has a
version of a catwoman suit on
but just like batman's suit it seems
like it's a beta version for something
bigger that's coming later on her
costume just seems very early version
much less refined than other versions of
catwoman's suit
this just seems like a scene of batman
getting ready to take out some mobsters
running a deal at the east side docks
we get a bigger voice over from the
riddler who's using a very batman style
trick of modulating his voice so that it
doesn't sound like paul
dano's voice this is what paul dino
looks like but in every time we see him
during the trailer he's bundled up with
his face covered
just asking batman if you are justice
please do not lie then you get a big
montage of a bunch of different scenes
the gang painted up to look like
skeletons that he fights then him
working on the batman costume
and then batman starting a fight inside
the police department
this seems like footage of the batmobile
getting shot up on the street
batman fighting catwoman to try and stop
her from stealing something
that's a scene out of the batman long
halloween comic book then you get that
who are you
scene that's an easter egg for the
michael keaton batman 1989 movie
very iconic line i think it made it into
all the original trailers for that movie
who are you i'm batman except robert
pattinson's batman replies
i'm vengeance then just proceeds to beat
him senseless for a couple more minutes
before he stands up
and just freaks out all the other gang
members who are looking at him in horror
like what just happened here then he
fires up that giant engine in the new
batmobile you get a little footage of
him driving it around through a chase
scene just crashing through stuff
he soaks a gunshot in that chest plate
of his
you get to see him use the grappling
hook you can kind of tell that they're
trying to give you footage
of all the different things and
abilities that batman is going to have
during the movie then you get the
official movie logo reveal
in red they actually revealed this a
couple days ago too so it's not that big
of a surprise
but you get that tag scene of him in the
batcave taking the cowl off with a
separate voice over probably from a
different scene of the riddler just
telling him
that he's going to find out very soon
how he's tied up in all this
in the very cool riddler question mark
easter eggs for the 2021 release date
the movie's coming out in october next
year close to halloween it's based on
the long halloween so even though it's a
bummer that it got delayed it was
originally coming out in june i feel
like it's also appropriate to release it
in october
it also gives off a very hardcore vibe
very
dark version of a batman movie i felt
like i didn't spot the penguin in any of
this trailer footage but if you did or
you spotted any other major batman
easter eggs that i didn't mention in the
video
just write them below in the comments
just to be clear how this connects to
everything else
the movie is not supposed to be
connected to the justice league movies
like the justice league snyder cut and
robert pattinson's batman
is not meant to be a younger version of
ben affleck's batman it's not a prequel
movie or anything like that
the movie exists in his own separate
continuity so when batman shows up in
the next justice league movie
it's supposed to be michael keaton's
batman from the multiverse
there were a bunch of other trailers
including a flash movie teaser with a
bunch of concept art for michael
keaton's batman with
ezra miller's flash so i'll do
breakdowns of all those other trailer
videos
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see those videos
when i post them everyone just let me
know in the comments what are you most
hyped up about for this new version of
the batman
and while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new wonder woman
1984 trailer video
and click here for all my other dc
fandom trailer videos like the justice
league snyder cut
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you